So one of my favorite lines
from Ernest Becker's book,
"The Denial of
Death," is the notion
that character is a vital lie.
So of course the self is a
house of cards constructed
with interconnected
webs of meanings,
cultural affiliations,
stereotypes,
artificial renderings
about who we
are as we navigate this world.
We construct self esteem.
We construct a foundation so
that we can stand with dignity.
But ultimately it's all the lie.
Human beings are food for worms.
The fact that we're
going to die imbues even
our greatest ecstasies
with a sting, with a burn.
I've had such a good life.
And so when he says
character is a vital lie,
he inserts the word "vital" in
there, as if to say "noble."
Man is noble even
if he is doomed.
if he is worm food.
Therein lies our beauty.
Therein lies our tragedy.
And therein lies the anxiety
that eats me up from inside
sometimes, and probably what
pushes me to try to make art.